après une semaine d'audiences les
assises de la nièvre ont donc condamné à
18 ans de réclusion
le jeune auteur du coup de couteau
mortel à nevers en 2017
suite à une altercation thibault cochet
est décédé il avait 22 ans
les précisions de rémy shiden 18 ans de
réclusion criminelle c'est la peine
infligée ce soir par la cour d'assises
de la nièvre à shenze beghi le jeune
homme de 23 ans est resté impassible à
l'annoncé du verdict devant une salle
pleine et tendu il a été reconnu
coupable de violences volontaires ayant
entraîné la mort avec intention de la
donner
la défense n'a pas réussi à faire
entendre la thèse du geste malencontreux
je vous propose d'écouter son avocat
j'espérais que l'intention soit écartée
parce que je pense qu'à la lecture du
dossier et d'après les déclarations de
monsieur midi ils n'avaient à aucun
moment l'attention de tout de suite
c'est quelque chose de fondamental pour
lui la firme encore aujourd'hui qu'il
n'a jamais eu l'intention de tuer la
victime pour la mer et les proches de
thibaut coché cette condamnation est un
soulagement après sept heures trente de
délibéré tous les accusés ont été
reconnus coupables mais le mobile de
l'agression fatale reste un mystère
les peines qui ont été prononcées sont
des peines qui me semblent reflète la
cruauté de l'acte qui a été commise sur
thibaut cocher les peines dans ce sens
là ne répare pas ne repartent jamais
effectivement la disparition de ce jeune
et nous ne réparons jamais la
disparition de ce jeune garçon mais il
n'empêche que on est dans un ordre
raisonnable là semble-t-il
parmi les trois autres accusés deux ont
été reconnus coupables de violences en
réunion et deux de non assistance à
personne en danger
les peines vont d'un à quatre ans
d'emprisonnement chems bégayer les trois
autres hommes n'ont pas encore indiqué
s'il compte faire appel de ce verdict